and now it can often feel like there's a
bit of Disconnect between Westminster
and what's actually going on in people's
lives around the country so each week on
the program we're trying to speak to
people from across the United Kingdom
and really talk about the challenges
that they're facing being on the cost of
living and energy crisis all the NHS
perhaps housing crime and more as well
too now here in Liverpool we are trying
to look a bit at the NHS we were
speaking about it earlier in the program
but just 10 days ago bosses at the Royal
Liverpool Hospital issued a full
capacity warning staff in a letter that
there was no space in resuscitation
areas and we can speak now to NHS staff
nurse Mark Anthony and here his story I
thank you very much for being with us
it's good to have you on the program
today I mean look we see the statistics
on the AHS waiting times ambulance
delays proponed appointments but I guess
I'm interested to hear The Human Side
what is it like to work on the in the
NHS at the minute
it's absolutely terrible for staff
working in the NHS at this moment they
were chronically understaffed uh staff
cannot even give the basic care for
patients and sometimes that you get
staff
getting in trouble because they've not
been able to give medication on time or
to get end up getting some performance
plans or disciplines and it's not their
fault at all this is the fault of the
government the government has let the
nursing down
terribly over the past 10 years we're
vastly underpaid and the Staffing is
absolutely so bad now that I fear for
patient safety I really do and and I
think I think that unless we have no
choice now of the Royal College of
Nursing to ballot for strike action
we're not doing this doing this um for
our own selfish names or anything like
that we were grossly underpaid uh nurses
are leaving in their droves at 20 000
left this year and now we end up a
situation where patients are so much at
risk now that that we have to do we have
to do things like this this government
is not listening and it never was going
to listen and we always but we've tried
very very hard to negotiate and we're
not getting anywhere
um just I want to hear a bit about what
it's like on the actual uh Wards you
know you were talking about the pressure
that nurses are under
um patient safety being put at risk um
what what kind of things do you mean is
it like people have been given the wrong
medication because there's a rash or
what is it like
what it is is that the girls are so
understaffed that you can actually get
situations where sometimes patients on
at times maybe not giving the medication
in time sometimes the situations where
where where the patients are put at risk
because because they could have health
and safety issues about Falls and things
like that that on the world there's also
also situations where just the basic
care sometimes you get some patience
unfortunately which is which is tragic
to say this that sometimes can be sat in
faces and nurses can't get to them in
times where they'll only try to and in
just the basic care of of even just
trying to trying to give them food and
things like that it's getting so bad now
that that that that that that that's
willing it I've never known it as bad as
this because I've been nursing 35 years
and now I I know it's a no from the
stories that I hear from my colleagues I
think that that this this is just a dire
situation and and and it's only going to
get worse
and you've been a nurse for 35 years so
you're still a nurse you're also a
member of the Royal College of Nursing
Union is this the worst that you've ever
seen it
it is definitely the worst ever I've
ever seen it
um and a true tragedy that was happening
now this is actually becoming the norm
if this carries on
um we're watching the NHS is just going
to lose its value as to what we used to
be I mean I'm proud to be a nurse I'm
proud to uh I joined it as a vocation I
joined it to represent to to want to
care for people and now it's not coming
that way you just come on the shifts and
you're totally stressed out you're
totally yeah and you know that's going
to be a really hard shift that they're
moving staff from one world to the other
from One hospital to the other it's like
shuffling the pack because it could get
a situation this the the the Staffing
levels to us towards a number of
patients is it can be can be drastic
something you can get two stuff and you
get 20 odd to 30 patients on on a Ward
and and that is just just not good
enough is absolutely it's dangerous it
is and and something has to be done and
if they don't don't pay nurses the
proper pay that they should be getting
and remember we've been taking a pay cut
over the past 10 years and and we're
constantly trying to battle for this
division because if you don't pay nurses
the proper pay the nurses are going to
continue to leave the service not
wanting to do that they have no choice
really we didn't join nursing to be dirt
poor we want we generation to want to
take care of the patients who want to
want to do be responsible for doing that
and we would love it we love our job but
not net but now we get we're pushed so
much now that we have no choice now but
to come out fighting
okay thank you very much indeed